becomes art for a great cause we're
talking about the ALS food is Art
fundraiser to help us talk about that we
have Don Newberg the executive director
for ALS Association of Nevada Don it's
always good to have you with us thank
you so much for having us we're so
excited about our event coming up next
Friday it sounds like an amazing event
uh because you're going to have on top
of great food an amazing view oh my gosh
yes we're going to be on the 108th floor
of the Strat so the entire observation
area is going to be closed except for
those that want to jump off the the sky
jump or whatever but it's call closed
for us and all for a great cause we're
going to have six different food
stations we're going to have a silent
auction and almost live auction a raffle
we're going to have live music it's just
going to be a great time what types of
food will be served well we're going to
be having a Lynette is going to be doing
Mexican food we have top of the world
we'll be there as well 108 eats is going
to do tiny little desserts we've got
Esther's kitchen going to be there wow
pts is going to be there so we've got
lots of great stops for people to grab
little bites good range oh yeah some of
the best chefs exactly that is fantastic
and all of this goes toward the ALS
Association tell us more about that and
what you do sure the ALS Association
provides care and support for
individuals in the state of Nevada that
have received an ALS diagnosis not only
to patients but also the caregivers and
the families that need the support as
well the average cost out of pocket for
someone that's received an ALS diagnosis
is about 250 000 a year so we step in
and we help with durable medical
equipment like I said support groups we
have a multi-disciplinary clinic which
helps bring all the disciplines together
occupational therapy Physical Therapy
speech respiratory so that the patients
don't have to go all over town to
receive treatment so we try to help
every single day everyone that we
receive we receive notice that they
received the diagnosis no cause no cure
for ALS the average lifespan is two to
five years and of course to provide all
those things you're talking about it
takes funds and that is a result of
donations and the money that will be
raised at events like the one coming up
so tell people how they can go how much
it costs and what they can expect sure
so an individual ticket is 250 dollars
for the the event this coming up week
you can go on our website which is
alsandv.org to purchase your tickets we
do have sponsorship opportunities
available as well if you'd like to come
as a big group of 10 people those
tickets would be two thousand dollars
but like you said all of those donations
and all everything raised from the
silent auction almost live auction
raffle all go directly back to our
programs and services Don it is always
good to have you with us we appreciate
everything you're doing in the community
so thanks for joining us today thank you
so much for having us it's really
important that we all work together no
doubt let's make sure people have the
information they need the ALS
Association Nevada chapter ALS Nevada is
holding what is its largest fundraising
event its food is Art Friday September
23rd goes from 6 until 10 p.m and again
that's on the 108th floor of the Strat
so beautiful view tickets on sale now at
ALS